hello everyone
my name is chu ki chan and today i'm
here to bust the android fragmentation
myth
yes really catchy title um you're
probably here because you've heard that
android has many many devices and super
difficult to develop on
and i'm hoping that by the end of this
talk
you will come home with some techniques
to not only deal with that but embrace
the idea that there are
many devices out there and it's a good
thing um
before i get started just want to get a
sense of your experience in the
development world so
um how many of you are mobile developers
either android
ios wow okay so maybe you already know a
lot of these stuff
how many of you are web developers
okay even more hands good because this
talk draws
very very heavily on web technologies on
techniques that
we are already doing in html in
javascript and css
um in particular if you look at
this and i'm trying to play the video
okay
i'll just let go all right um
there's this thing called web browser
and it's that's pretty much
infinitely sized right you can drag it
to whatever dimension whatever ratio you
want
and it's not the end of the world we
deal we have been making web pages for a
long long time
and using the same techniques that we
have been doing for web development
you can make android apps just as
responsive and
also progressive meaning that it will
take advantage of the features that are
available on that particular device
but you know will not crash and burn
when you're
running on an older device i'm going to
very quickly run you through
hello world in android so that you have
a good idea of how the program is
structured
hello world uh very boring it's just a
screen that says the word hello world
well how do you write that in android we
have this thing called an activity and
if you're familiar with
web development this is almost like your
javascript is where the logic goes
and within your activity you will set
the content view meaning that you are
setting
the presentation layer essentially your
html
and the way it works is that you put
this xml in the layout
folder which will get then compiled into
something that android understands
this xml looks not too scary i hope
the idea is that for example we are
calling textview meaning that we want to
display text
and then you see things like the width
and the height are wrapped content
this is android ways of saying just take
as much space as you need
right instead of saying that this is
going to be 100 pixels wide
the interesting here on the point now is
also their attributes like
id which again if you're familiar with
web development
it's just like an id you put on a dom
node
which you can then do a fine view by id
on your
activity and then you can have a pointer
to it and then you can send value to it
all right so that's android in the
whirlwind right so
the idea is that there's a presentation
and then the logic
so what makes it possible to do
android on so many devices is that it's
actually a declarative layout system
so now something is slightly different
from our hollow world here we have a
button
that's in the middle of the screen right
so
if someone gave you this as a task and i
should implement it
if you come from some other platforms or
some other
disciplines you may be tempted to say
aha all right i have a button
and i'm going to put it in this x y
coordinate on screen
and that's how i'm going to lay out the
button and some of these
are smiling what happens when you say
rotate the screen then if you have an
absolute coordinate like that well i
would stay
very faithfully at that position and
look really weird instead what you want
is put it in the center of the screen
and this is what i mean by declarative
layout
in android it's in the system
all you need to do is just tell android
that hey i want to assign a gravity
value of center
center is a short form for center
horizontal and center vertical
so android will depending on how large
of the screen computes xy coordinate for
you and put it
in the center of the screen so far so
good nothing
rocket science right you just think like
that and stuff
some some of the um i guess developers
come from a world where they take
mocs right with absolute coordinate and
then they just stick things on
and they will be very confused when they
come to android and say i can't do that
how do i
ever lay out things on screen but if you
turn
the head around and think decoratively
it's not that bad
so now something slightly more
complicated say you're building this
game
that want to find the difference between
two images
and what you want to do is actually
split the screen equally
so that you have as much real estate as
possible for your two images
and by the way can you actually spot the
difference
a little break
nobody can you see the i think i will
play with my laser pointer
there's a little difference here
so um anyway that is not the point of
this slide the slider to show you the
layout
and how are we going to achieve that so
now we have a new element that's called
linear layout
what linear layout does is allow you to
lay things out
linearly in our case we're doing it
vertically
just as i showed you on the screenshot
one after another
and the curious thing is that now what
we're doing
in the layout instead of saying wrap
content that i did earlier
what it does is for the width it says
match parent which means
just take as much width as there is
given to me by the parent
which is the linear layout which say the
same thing again so it's going to fill
up the full screen
now the height we are saying zero
you're like what take zero height what
this means is that i'm telling android
well you know
at the time i'm writing this layout i
don't know how big it is but i'm gonna
give you some more information i'm gonna
give you weight
so i'm telling android that give weight
one to the first
image and also one to the second image
and android is going to go ahead and say
okay we have a total of two and then
divide equally
so that layout actually is still have
something missing so i have the two
images
right that i specified in my linear
layout can someone spot something on
this screen that i have not spelled out
on the previous slide on the
xml a bit of a trick question here
so that's image one and then there's
image two
and i have a divider in the middle so
how am i gonna do that
so here i'm actually telling android
that well for the divider i'm going to
give you
a specific dimension i want it to be 1dp
and then it's going to assign this much
real estate to the divider and the rest
of the screen is going to divide using
the weight
1dp what is dp
dp stands for density independent pixel
and it's a very important concept in
android which is why it's so big on the
screen
um so i i'm sure you have heard of
retina and things of that kind right so
mobile devices are not all of the same
density on the display and this is how
android deals with that so instead of
designing things to pixel values what
you
need to do is think in terms of dps
meaning that say i want something that's
this wide on screen right
but if you have a device that is double
density
then it will automatically shrunk into
half size if you are doing it in pixel
value
so this is a convenient way to say well
i want it to be 100
dp and then if you are on a double
density device it will multiply that
into 200 pixels
um again not rocket science but just
things that the system already built in
anticipating that there will be a lot of
different kinds of devices out there
right so now we have two images and we
have a divider
great again what happens when i rotate
the device
so if i use the same layout which i
spelled out earlier
that divides the height equally then
we'll get this which is this teeny tiny
little robot which is not very good for
spotting the difference
what we actually want is this i want to
instead
divide the screen horizontally i want to
split up the width
how do you do that well the layout is
relatively straightforward
instead of splitting the
height i'm splitting width using the
weight and then i'm switching the
linear layout to use horizontal
but the interesting part on this slide
is actually the title
so earlier i showed you that i put the
xml file into this folder called
layout and you can also put it in a
different folder say
it means that if i detected that
the device is of landscape orientation
android is going to go ahead and load
this layout instead of
the normal layout the default layout
from the layout folder
and the nice thing about this is if any
of you do
rails development it's kind of the same
idea like you're using the structure
of your program to tell the system what
it needs to do
and if you notice that i have also here
things like id
which matches whatever i have in the
earlier slide so the
logic doesn't need to change right if
the logic is say oh
i want to load this particular image and
put it in image one
depending on the layout of the screen
it's just going to
find the correct image view and stick it
in
so this is just to show you how you're
going to actually
put that into your system so you put it
in a different folder with the same name
and you are still calling this r dot
layout.um
activity underscore main which is
android way of compiling all these
resources that's what r stands for from
the folders
and then well i have this one identifier
that says i want
activity main as the layout and then at
runtime the
system will know that oh the device is
rotated it's on
landscape orientation i'm going to go
ahead and use the proper
layout file so this is a brief
introduction to layout folders
the normal one and then the landscape
one
there's actually a lot more you can do
with layout folders
this is not even the complete list i'm
just giving you a flavor of what's there
i've showed you earlier the layout land
and i'm putting it into the layout
folder with an xml
you can also do other things like
drawable drawable is essentially
png most of the time but there are also
other kinds of drawables
and here what i'm doing is saying that
if
i am of a high density device
use this image for the launcher which is
what you see on the home screen
this way you can have a much more finer
grained icon
for devices that have the pixels to
display them but still you know for low
density
devices you can put something in the
ldpi folder
that not only it's not just you take an
image and you scale it down like you are
actually
able to for example change a little bit
of the design so that it
looks better when you have not as much
pixel to express yourself
now you can also combine these variables
so i can say that i want a drawable
that get loaded when i have a large
screen and of landscape orientation
which is what i'm doing here with my app
this is an
app that teaches people how to write
chinese so i have this beautiful
background which i'm not sure if you can
see on the screen there's a very subtle
bamboo forest behind the monkey okay you
just have to believe me well anyway
monkeys don't live in bamboo forest
right but my designer said yeah it makes
it look chinese so let's just put some
bamboo on but you can't even see it
anyway
so the idea is that when i have the real
estate on screen i want to give the
experience
of having this nice background but when
i'm on a small screen
i actually again you have to trust my
word on this
now it does not have any bamboo on the
background what it has
is a gradient so when i'm on the phone
i actually don't really want to bother
with all those extra declarative
elements
because it's a little bit distracting so
in android actually make it fairly easy
for you to do all you have to do is you
put
the proper drawable in the proper folder
and then it will
get determined for you and something
that is a little bit different besides
the folder name
is that i'm calling this
splash.xml and instead of splash.png
what is a xml drawable
here i'm actually again declarative
right i'm declaring that i want the
background to be a rectangle
with a gradient of this dark color and
this end color
which if you read rgb very fluently
it'll be from some shade of green to
some other shade of green
and then what android does is then it
will take the value from start to end
and then do all the math and extrapolate
for you so
if you have a small screen fine it will
fill it up
if you have a bigger screen it will
still fill up with the same start and
end color
but with a very smooth gradient right
because if you imagine you're generating
this gradient
in photoshop say right you can only give
that gradient so many pixel values at
some point there will be banding
right it will just have to repeat some
of the
color because you gave it this much to
put on screen and then the screen
actually ended up being this big
so having a declarative drawable
means that you can adapt to any screen
size you want essentially
by just computing the value on the fly
so if you want something a little bit
more complicated instead of just a
straight up
gradient say a pattern so somehow you
have this app that talks about bees and
you want to put in this
nice honeycomb background which if you
just naively put in
a wallpaper essentially of a fixed
aspect ratio and then you use the exact
same thing
on a horizontal aspect ratio then you
get corn on the cob instead of
the honeycomb which doesn't theme very
well so
how are we going to deal with that well
there's this technique called tau
backgrounds which
you just take a repeatable pattern and
put it on this whole screen
this is something not very new
some of you are already smiling i'm not
quite sure whether this is because
i'm taking it from geocities who knows
geocities
all right i'm talking to the right crowd
yeah it's been around for a while taking
an
entire image and feel on the screen so
i'm putting it not to
poke at your city but to tell you that
there is no reason for us to be afraid
of so many android devices all these
techniques have been out there for a
long time
it's not rocket science and android
actually takes a lot of this concept
from the web
and use it in the system but it also
improves it a little bit
so here this is the syntax for doing
tile background
i'm just telling android that go ahead
and load this tile.png file
from the drawable folder and repeat it
over the screen and when i'm going to
use this
tiling background all i'm going to do is
just tell android that hey
load this from the drawable folder which
it says drawable that's how it matches
and then i'm calling the background one
which is know that it's an xml
and then we'll go ahead and use the
launcher and lay it on screen
declaratively so i mentioned a little
bit that it actually improves over what
we have on the web
so we have actually not just the repeat
kind of thailand we have three different
tiling modes
the first one is clamp which is a little
bit strange to use for a background it
repeats the edge color
and this is mostly used for things that
pertains to for example if you're taking
a text
view and you want to put something on
that's a little bit declarative and then
you just want to have a
solid background for the rest of your
text but what i really like
is mira so mira it says repeats with
alternating
mirror images um essentially what
happens is if you take this
tile which is the little triangle on the
corner
and then you go ahead and flip it when
you're opponent
edge whenever you see an edge you're
always mirroring this has the automatic
nice effect that is seamless right if
you look at the repeat
on the second row you can clearly see
the
the boundaries between the tiles and
sure you know like when you go to the
geoct website you can download seamless
tiles
but as a developer i have no idea how to
generate seamless styles
and i actually was working with a
developer on my monkey
with a designer on my ranking monkey
write app and he made me this beautiful
wood grain background
and i was trying to explain to him that
i will have multiple
devices with multiple resolutions and i
will need the background to be titlable
can you cut it in a way so that it's
seamlessly terrible and he's like
no i don't know what you're talking
about i'm like no you know like and i
tried to show him examples he's just
like not getting it and finally
i discovered this mode i'm like all
right that's okay i'm just gonna cut it
myself
and then use mirror mode so that it will
be seamless
so i really like this particular little
trick
and here is another it's almost like a
tiling algorithm as well but
what i'm showing you here is a screen on
my app that
shows essentially the list of characters
you can practice on this app
and you're like okay so what you have a
grid view your shows a bunch of icons
the thing is when you're thinking about
this this is on the 10
inch tablet right so what if i'm running
on the phone do i still display
four characters per rule then what will
happen they will become
teeny tiny right so what we are doing
here instead
is using this particular android
construct for the grid view called
autofit
instead of telling it hey it's always
120 pixels or better 120 dps
i'm telling android that well actually
sorry i got it backwards it's not
telling androids always four columns i'm
telling android that
i want each of my character to be 120 dp
and then go ahead and work out how big
the screen is or in my case i'm actually
not taking the full screen so how big my
parent is
and just you know do your math and
there's a lot more parameters here
in not just the autofit i'm telling it
how big the character itself is
and also how much padding and spacing
i'm doing and here
i'm using this construct called at
diamond
what is that um so this is essentially
one level of indirections
instead of hard coding into my layout
the
dimensions for the padding and the
spacing and the column width
i'm telling android say that i want the
padding to be
this much and the spacing to be this
much so there are two advantages here
so one is um if you look at here i want
the corresponding
spacing and the vertical spacing to be
the same so with one level of
interaction when i'm marking with the
perimeters
i don't have to make sure that you know
i typed it twice to be the same
but more importantly again when i'm
doing this
resource folder trick it's not just on
the
parent level that have this parent
layout if the parent layer refer to
parameters that are in different folders
it will for example share the parent
layout that didn't change it's a great
view with multiple things in it
but when i'm on the last screen i can go
ahead and make the characters larger and
further apart
so if you are dividing your
layout and logic into smaller chunks
like that it's actually
very powerful you can have a layout
that's shared but then
you want to do something slightly
different for bigger screens or dancer
screens or
even japanese screens if you want to do
that the resourceful have many different
parameters that you can
target to so with that
on the seven inch tablet it will show
three
characters and on the phone it will show
two characters
so i maintain the size and the way
i chose that is because um here if you
get this teeny tiny thing on the screen
it just doesn't look very nice right so
again like if you haven't noticed the
theme yet i love these techniques uh
think about what you want instead of
think about how many pixels you are
going to put on screen
and moving on so that was mostly about
the display layer how do you put
things on screen progressive means that
i want to be able to enhance my app when
my
phone has newer apis right
so why am i showing this slide again i
told you that this is all about layout
well actually
it is not just about layout you can also
target
different parts depending on the
platform you're on so
here it says v4 v11 so those are the
api versions and if you are familiar
with android
then you will immediately translate your
head that says okay
v4 is donut and v14 is ice cream
sandwich
i mean it doesn't matter the bigger
number is the newer os's
and the cool thing about this is that
you can go ahead and use that to load
elements that are only available in
newer
platforms so here i'm giving you this
example called toggle button
so before ice cream sandwich before
essentially 14
we have this not so pretty thing called
toggle buttons which when you click
it will switch from on to off and with a
color change
and then in ice cream sandwich there's
this new ui element called switch
which looks much nicer and with the
functionality exactly the same
and they both derive from compound
buttons so the
api behind is also the same so if you
want to write an
app that works on all devices
you will but you would still like to
take advantage of this new sexy switch
what you can do is that you can put
this xml called compound button
in your layout folder so layout without
any
of those different declaration um
parameters it means the default layout
so by default load the toggle button
which is available on all platforms
but if you are running version 14
and when you when you do that it's
actually version 14 or above
go ahead and load the switch and then
what you can do
is when you have a layout you want to
use
either the toggle button or the switch
you can go ahead and just say include
the compound button right and then you
can do it multiple times as many
compound buttons you have and you can go
ahead and do that and the system will
know
oh okay i'm running on ice cream
sandwich i can go ahead and look at the
v14
directory and low switch instead of
toggle button
and the way you will use that in class
in your activity most typically
is that you will go ahead and do define
view by id again
but this time we'll cast it not to
toggle button
or to switch but to the parent class
which is the compound button
which understands things like if it's
checked or not so here for example i'm
saying that
oh if the turbo button is not pressed
slow down the computer
does that ring a bell so when i was a
kid i have this tower
computer that you know you can play
games on and then this is magic button
that when you press it will turbo it and
make it faster i thought
wow people who make computers are so
smart and yeah later i found out that
you know that
that's not what it's doing what it's
doing is when you are not pressing
the button it just slows down um has to
do
with the the clock cycle and games like
programming to the clock cycle
anyway so the idea is that when you have
something that is available on the newer
platform
you can use the resource folder track to
dynamically load the proper type
but sometimes even that is not powerful
enough you will actually have to do
some java code we are not afraid of java
right
so for example here i'm you know going
through the android documentation and
looking for that particular function
that i need and i found it
harass except that it says
api level five which means that if i
want
it to work on api level 4 or earlier
no dice that doesn't work but i really
want this function i want it
when the system have it what to do
fortunately android provides this class
called android.os.build
which gives you the version that you're
running on
earlier it's a string but then it's just
a string one
two or three so then they later
introduce
an integer so that you don't have to
parse integer from the string which
everybody was doing
so what you can do is that you can
detect
the level of the os
using the build class and then enhance
your
program when you have functions that are
available
what do i mean so here what i have is
i want to use this um get memory
function that i showed you earlier
to know how big the uh the the the heap
size is essentially
so what i do is this well i just give it
a default value
so that there's some reasonable behavior
if i don't have access to that
particular
function and i'll go ahead and grab the
android version and then if the android
version is bigger than
what it supports here it says um eclair
which is
the constant five um i'm going to
diverge a little bit because i think
it's very interesting if you're
thinking wait a minute you're telling me
that you're trying to run this on the
old device
and you're having this constant that is
only i mean by definition available for
newer devices right how would an
old device know the existence of a clear
version five
in in the future um so no worries
actually this
is a public static final end
which means that if you're in java it's
going to be in line so
what i see as the programmer is the nice
parameter is the constant but when they
get compiled down it will actually be
just a constant five so
older versions understand numbers so
they will see it's five
and if it's not bigger than five it's
going to go ahead and skip this block
but if you're running on newer version
then you can go ahead and use the
get memory class function now here i
have a level of interaction
and that's because the way that all the
android was
implemented is it will try to resolve
all the function pointers essentially
right so if i go ahead and call this
well
core and put this get memory class
function
even if it's protected by the if block
the
vm will be like oh well where is this
memory class defined i don't know
blow up right but fortunately java is
also very lazy
so if i put it in a static class helper
essentially what java does is that okay
um there is this thing that i need to do
which this class knows and i will just
let the runtime
resolve that at runtime so it knows the
existence of this class but doesn't know
the guts of the class it didn't know
that secretly this class contains things
that doesn't understand
but at runtime we never actually go
through this box so we are all safe
you actually only need to do this trick
for really really old devices
since version five and above the the
dalvik vm is actually smarter
it doesn't go ahead and try to resolve
everything in advance so
i'm just showing you this technique in
case you're stuck with really really
really old things that you need to
support right
so again this is the formula for doing
progressive enhancement
you're very important to have a default
behavior
right so that you're not just having
uninitialized values when the
function that you want to use is not
available so you have a default value
and then you try to detect the version
that you're running on
and then when you have a system that is
newer than the api that you'll be using
you can go ahead and call it um
there is also one other thing that you
can do besides saying that all right all
stuff you're stuck i'm not going to have
this nice functionality and new devices
for us i have new functionality for you
you can also
just ship whatever functionality you
need and
the concept of support library is
essentially
taking components that android rollout
for newer os's
bundle it into a library and then you
package it
into your app and then ship it out um
there's the official support library
which has a lot of different things in
it
um so some of them are not really ui
elements like an llu cache
some of it like to draw layout is the
thing that you can slide out from the
side
um so the idea is that even though you
are running older devices
if you just package whatever new
functionality you need
well then your net app knows how to do
it so besides the
official support library they're also
android is a very has a very thriving
open source community that has put out a
lot of nice libraries here
these are just a few examples and i'm
going to show
you one that i was using in my app so
like there was a lot of hands up so
maybe you know this already so there is
this thing that you can use
to do multi-pane ui that is called view
pager
which is in the support library which is
great but
it's very hard to tell the user that you
can swipe it's just one image on screen
so the view page indicator are these
little circles in the bottom
which is done by a programmer that is
just open sourcing it and now you have
this little circle that will hinge the
user and this looks exactly the same
whether i'm running
on jelly bean or gingerbread because i
am shipping
this ui element within the app
all right so i've told you a lot of
different things
i told you how to do responsive layout
with
first of all a mindset you have to think
declaratively instead of in absolute
coordinate
once you are there there are a lot of
tools that the system have
to help you with it so you can declare
things with
dps with density independent pixels and
you can use the
resource folder so that you can have
different layout
for different configurations of devices
and also you can have things like a xml
drawable which again
allows you to decoratively declare
images which i think is pretty cool
and then i also show you how to have
progressive functionality
again meaning that if you have some
shiny new function that you want to call
but you are also needing to support all
devices what do you do
resource folder again if you can't tell
yeah this is one of my favorite tricks
to do
to deal with all these devices out there
you can use the
version construct to ask the system to
load particular resources
when you're running on a new system you
can also do the version track
which is the android.os.build class so
you can compare
the running version with the version
that your library is available and then
only
do it when it's there and finally you
can have support libraries so that you
just ship functionalities that is
lacking
and with that is the end of this talk
but
i have given two other talks that is
also on android which goes into two
different directions
the fluid android layout talk goes a
little bit even deeper
like more examples of what i did with my
app that supports both the
phone and the device um then the
beautiful android
talk goes into more details about doing
more things like
the declarative layout for the
gradient for example so i have
techniques like if you want to put
gradient on text how would you do that
and if you're interested you can go
ahead and there the slides
the the points of slides that have a
little youtube video and
attach on the corner so you can actually
watch me speak as well
and if you have more questions and just
want to know more about android this is
where you'll find me on the internet
thank you